[Musique]
petit à petit c'est là des musicos sont
imposés que je crois qu'on peut dire
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup d'endroits
privé comme ça à paris en tout cas où se
sont réunis où se réunissent et se
réuniront autant d'artistes célèbres et
importants sont venus ici beaucoup de
gens et également des instrumentistes
comme richter ou navarra et bien
d'autres mais petit à petit j'ai voulu
donner à ces lundis musicaux une couleur
spéciale les me cantonner dans le champ
et c'est ce qui est arrivé
principalement depuis la saison dernière
est tout à fait à partir de la saison
qui s'ouvre où il n'y a plus que des
artistes de l'art lyrique qui se
présenteront au cas de la télé vous
allez être copier c'est ça qui est bien
pour le public
oui c'est parfait il y aura sûrement des
directeurs théâtre qui font la même
chose mais ils ont tout à fait raison
raison parce que ça sera très bien
alors vous êtes pianiste je crois savoir
en plus non pas du tout mais comme comme
il faut bien nous un piano alors comme
ça c'est amusant de pouvoir s'imaginer
qu'on est pianiste se dire dans une
salle vide qu'elle ait l'air que vous
aimez le plus celui que vous jouez comme
vous avez le spleen pierre bergé celui
je joue qu'en juin piano que je suis non
pas moi c'est toujours la veuve joyeuse
et bon alors vous nous donner juste
quelques mesures téléspectateurs non
mais c'est comme ça c'est un musée du
vin et moi
[Musique]
on
au mans
[Musique]
vous voyez c'est une première et spa
c'est la première année
alors puisque nous avons la chance
d'avoir deux des cantatrices wii qui
sont programmées au théâtre de l'athénée
on peut peut-être les présentez vous
venez va présenter christine barbeau et
hanna schaer mais je crois que qu'elles
vont se présenter très bien toutes les
deux et puis on peut te dire qu'on ouvre
les lundis musicaux la saison avec cette
grande cantatrice que tout le monde
connaît qui s'appelle un hameau faut et
puis les lundis musicaux c'est aussi une
façon de se faire plaisir à soi même
c'est pas c'est pas seulement une façon
de deux comme ça agitée dans un shaker
des noms célèbres c'est aussi rechercher
les gens les aimer les amener
[Musique]
on
le passé
[Musique]
où
il faut
[Musique]
oh
l'estrie
[Musique]
oh
longtemps
c'est faux
oh
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]